Alright, let's see if we can make some sense
of this. First, we convert 64 kilobytes into bytes by
multiplying by 1,024 bytes, which is 65,536 bytes. Next
we convert this number into the number of packets by
dividing by the size of the packet, and that
turns out to be approximately 45 packets. Next we can
plug in the numbers that we have into the
formula that we have here. We know that the roundtrip
time is 100 milliseconds. We have 45 packets that we
need to transfer, and the initial congestion window is 10
packets. Now, this actually simplifies to three, so what we actually
have is 100 milliseconds times three, or approximately 300 milliseconds.
>> But Ilia, I have a question for you. Why do these brackets look weird?
>> This is actually the ceiling function, which means you need
to round up the number to the next greatest integer
once you figure out the answer to this log function.
>> Oh, thank you.
>> So, the final answer is 300 milliseconds, which
is quite a bit of time. That's said, note
that this is only true for new speed connections.
Check the link in instructor notes for more details.